[Music]
is a columnist
a senior researcher at the center for
social justice welcome to
spectator tv let me just go through some
of the things
that i think the report says and you can
mark my card
one of the conclusions would seem to be
that when we look at disparities
in performance between various ethnic
groups
that family structure and social class
often have a bigger impact than race
is that correct yes you see this
uh thank you for having me on uh before
i uh begin
uh you see this in a lot of the areas we
looked at we looked at education
crime and policing health and
employment and enterprise and just to
take
education as an example uh socio we
commissioned
um a bespoke study from the university
of oxford and actually
it clearly showed that socioeconomic
differences
are the key drivers of um sort of
academic performance across different
ethnic groups
but even then it's completely uh
complicated as well because what you see
is ethnic minority children actually
at the same social class even go on to
outperform
um their white counterparts in many
instances and often
the disparities in family structures
between the different ethnic groups are
absolutely
staggering but if you look at the group
that has the highest level of
lone parenthood this is caribbean kids
we're talking six in ten caribbean kids
growing up in lone parent um households
and we know that uh working class uh
households are also more likely to be
a lone parent households than middle
class households so you can
very much begin to map the uh ethnic
differences in outcomes uh
with the um with these other factors
such as socioeconomic
and uh family structures well messi that
brings me to the next question i wanted
to ask because i think the report
gives the data that shows that that the
that among all the ethnic groups that
make up uh britain and
uh there are many of them sometimes you
kind of lump them as if they're an
undifferentiated mass but actually
there's incredible diversity among all
the ethnic uh groups
and that the only ethnic
group every other every ethnic group
performs better than whites
bar black caribbean pupils
is that correct yes that's uh
correct andrew and um as i say this is
why we simply can't um
make this a bone versus white issue and
actually beyond that
you you get um people saying you know
black exclusions for
instance black outcomes you can't even
do that because actually what we see is
african children outperform white kids
outperform
you know the the kind of average and
black caribbean kids are one of the
worst performing so even once you start
saying well there must be racism towards
black kids
because exclusions you know african kids
are not no more likely to be excluded
from school than their white british
counterparts again it's the black
caribbean
um kids that see these high levels of
exclusions and then that
then you have to ask yourself hang on a
second is this
institutional racism blanket explanation
adequate or is there
other things going on that mean even if
you're black
your outcomes are likely to be different
depending on whether you're
an african immigrant or you know a third
generation black caribbean child
and i was reading that the the pay gap
between
ethnic groups the average among ethnic
groups and the average in the white
population the pay gap is down now to
2.3 percent
and something that i thought gave great
hope for the future
was that your report says it's now
negligible
for people under 30. yes that's right so
uh the ethnic pay gap and this is the
between white british majority and
ethnic minorities is down to 2.3
which is the lowest level you know in a
decade so again you see that
you know upwards trajectory i know there
are a lot of people in the race lobby
who don't want to accept
at all that there might have been any
progress over the last
you know couple of decades but you know
the data is very clear on this and as
you say the
um under 30s don't see any you know
statistically significant wage gaps
between them
so again you know there's uh
this idea that we haven't progressed or
that um we're kind of
uh cherry-picking data to show where
there might be bits of progress and
hiding the other data it's not true
because this is you know
official statistics these are national
statistics and
um you know if they want to argue with
that they they shouldn't be arguing with
us quite frankly they should be arguing
with the
you know the statisticians who produce
these robust
uh data sets the report does not say
there's no racism in britain that would
be absurd we still see
many individual examples of it or racist
attitudes and
and so on that that cannot be just uh
hidden away you see it particularly in
social media but your report also says
that some communities in our country are
still
haunted by historic racism
what did you mean by that well
this is kind of speaking to the fact
many of uh
we know for a fact that people feel that
there are
there is significant racism in this
country you we can i can point to uh the
the
official crime survey for england and
wales which shows actually racially
motivated crimes have gone down
massively over time but it
it's the case that it doesn't change
that people very much feel
that that that not reflective of their
reality
and what what that's speaking to is a
kind of a legacy because
of course britain was severely racist
a long time ago and there was
considerable racism
only you know four or five decades ago
and these are people who
there's many people living in the
country today who would have been
experiencing racism on a daily basis
and so yes there is a lot of people in
the country
will have will be living with that
legacy of feeling that you know
britain's not for them
um that they perhaps won't have
experienced
the kind of prosperity that many of the
younger generations
have experienced so there is definitely
a legacy but you know
we've had kind of um people coming out
today
particularly on the left and kind of you
know these work activists and saying
the report has denied racism that's not
the case i thought
we have said in fact if they look on
just the first recommendation
the first recommendation is to tackle
racist um language and to tackle
kind of racism and to empower the
equality's watchdogs to do that
and on page 36 we actually set out a
kind of framework so that
we can properly kind of disentangle the
different manifestations
of racism instead of just kind of
applying a blanket um
accusation of racism on everything
well anybody who thinks we haven't come
a long way didn't live
in our country in the 50s or 60s i
remember
a by-election campaign uh in a labor
seat in which the
uh i think it was the tory candidate
though i should be careful
the their election slogan was if you
want
n-word for a neighbor then vote labor
so i think we've we're not there yet but
we've come a long way
from attitudes uh uh like like that
and when i when i look at your report it
seems
things are more complicated and more uh
sophisticated more news race is uh
obviously a factor in some things but
family influence i think your report
says social class
culture religion and so on are all just
as important and sometimes
maybe more important than race is that
correct
yeah that's correct and um you know what
fundamentally what we're saying is
disparity is not always discrimination
in the same way that you know everybody
knows or should know that
correlation is not causation so
our approach was to a kind of inductive
approach
we start with the data and then we kind
of let the data lead us
and what the data showed is that there
are all these um
other factors and also that there are
disparities that really
can't really be explained by kind of
this white on
um to use that dreaded term
racism one of the shocking things one of
the most shocking things for me
in the report was that black
young black people between age 16 to 24
are 24 times more likely to be victims
of homicide
than their white counterparts that is
for me
you know on a scandalous level um
you know to say okay well that must be
proof of racism well actually that
you're basically kind of ignoring all
the other variables that might be
driving that
clearly there's issues of deprivation
there's issues of
perhaps even absent fathers which i'm
sure you know people don't like to go
down that route
um there's all these issues that we
really could be talking about
um to tackle what is you know a shocking
statistic which is that you know 24
times more likely to be killed
um so these are the sorts of
conversations we should be having
and instead we get led down this path of
you know
a tit-for-tat you know conversation
about oh
is it institutional racism does it exist
does it not and then you get ridiculous
things as well from i saw clive lewis
the labor
mp his response uh to the report was to
tweet
an image of a kkk um person so
you know that kind of level of debate
is just i mean i would say it's
laughable but
it's not even funny at all i just don't
think the people who are criticizing
this report
um are have actually come out with
anything
to tell us why exactly what data they
disagree with
what recommendations they disagree with
and why so it's you know
again we're getting into a lot of
tit-for-tat identity politics stuff
instead of dealing with the real issues
but a final question to you you must
have known you were going to stir up a
hornet's nest here i mean
the current fashion on both sides of the
atlantic
uh and perhaps even a growing fashion uh
fashion uh in anti-racism is to see
all ethnic disadvantage all ethnic
disadvantage
through the prism of white supremacy
and you're challenging that head-on so
it's quite
a threat to those who traditionally have
seen themselves
as the people who spoke up for racial
disadvantage
yes that's right and i think that is the
battle on our hands and
you know all these things like kind of i
mean one of the
i can never pronounce her surname but dr
scholler who's always kind of brought
out by mainstream channels to provide
commentary on race
you know her her response to the report
was to call dr tony sewell
a token black man who was spreading
white supremacist lies
now tony saw is has dedicated his life
to
supporting ethnic minority people
fulfill their full potential he runs a
charity that helps
young um black and ethnic minority kids
go into stem careers
to suggest he's spreading white
supremacist lies i mean that just shows
the level of detachment from reality and
actually
these people try to intimidate you into
being silent
about the days of being silent about all
these disparities and
um you know to to to coin a phrase i
won't be silent and i won't be silenced
andrew well they've had it their own way
for so long mercy
that you've now threatened them with
this report so i'm not surprised that
they're going to be
kicking back because their very purpose
of existing
is undermined by what your report says
messi thank you for joining us on
spectator tv i hope you'll
come back as this issue develops it's
not going to go away
[Music]
you